hello tumors McDonald thank you very
much and you for joining us on the
program this morning what does President
Biden have to say today in order for
Stormont to be back up and running do
you think
well good morning Kay and there is a
great excitement here in Ireland that
the president has now landed and
commences his uh his tour today
initially in Belfast as you say I think
undoubtedly
um President Biden will reflect on the
great success of the last 25 years
building peace
um I think you would you will obviously
reflect also on on the huge role of the
United States of America in that I have
no doubt that he perhaps shares
certainly my disappointments sinfain's
disappointment that on this occasion
Mark in 25 years of the peace Accord
that the institutions aren't up and
running that we still don't have
government in Belfast and that the dup
continues its boycott so I I hope there
will be a very positive
forward-looking message I have no doubt
there will be but also a very clear
message that now is the time to to end
the boycott to stop this sense of limbo
and to deliver for people in the north
of Ireland of all political Persuasions
the government that they deserve were
nearly a year on now from the election
last May
um it was a visit by a previous visit by
a president President Clinton that got
all finally got all sides together to
get the Good Friday agreement signed
do you feel that the presence of another
president could make the difference I
suppose is my question
yes I mean I I mean I think throughout
this uh process over many many decades
at the importance of international
Partners in making peace in Ireland has
been absolutely essential and none more
so than the United States of America so
this is K a very significant visit it
comes at a particular moment in time in
Irish history 25 years of Peace
reflecting on all of that but crucially
also looking forward and the president
is as you know joined by Joe Kennedy the
uh appointed Envoy of his administration
to Ireland to the north of Ireland and
his brief is explicitly economic so
there's a huge appetite here and uh in
the United States and I hope also in
Britain with the British government to
make big economic progress in the north
of Ireland is a huge opportunity here
for jobs for investment for improving
people's standard and quality of life
and I really hope that everybody is
forward-looking enough at smart enough
to grasp that opportunity and certainly
Joe Kennedy's role is to work to partner
with people in Ireland to take advantage
of investment opportunities
opportunities for Innovation and the
clear opportunity that the north of
Ireland has in maintaining access to the
European markets for goods that's a very
very significant thing that was secured
in the aftermath of brexit through
negotiation a very long very painstaking
negotiation all of that is now done and
it is now really a moment for all of us
to to move on any further limbo or delay
is not good I mean it's it's
unacceptable for people in the north of
Ireland it's bad for Ireland as a whole
and it's bad for politics more generally
it's bad for the anglo-irish
relationship we don't need inertia we
need energy and momentum and positivity
and a forward-looking uh View and I very
much expect
and hope that President Biden and the
American delegation will bring that
sense of purpose and also a sense of
urgency the dup have had time to reflect
I think people have been patient and
respectful with them but now is the
moment for Action I mean things cannot
strike on without government for much
longer okay that was a chunky answer
wasn't it let me take you back to at the
start of that answer when you said uh 25
years of Peace others would say mostly
peace not least
um thugs terrorists thugs trying to
murder a police officer in front of his
young son
yes absolutely and
um that is uh noticeable okay thank God
because it is now the exception that's
an exceptional uh trauma and one which
as you know was roundly condemned by one
and all and and the response to that
awful act uh right across the community
could not be missed and those that
carried out that action
um do not enjoy the support of uh any
element of Irish Society they are
destructive they aren't misguided and
let me say as an Irish Republican as a
committed United Ireland or they do
absolutely nothing to advance the cause
of Irish reunification all they do is so
um Division and and fear
um and I would ask them to desist and
stop and I speak for the vast vast vast
majority of people again of all
political Persuasions right across our
Island petrol bombs thrown at the police
on Easter Monday during the uh
commemoration of the Easter risings back
in 1916 suspected pipe bombs found in a
cemetery this week dear Lord
well I mean the the 19th Easter is a
very political moment it's a moment for
many of of religious uh celebration and
marketing but it's also very political
because uh we commemorate the 1916
Rising uh right across the island there
are hundreds and hundreds of
commemorations a big state commemoration
in Dublin and they are marked uh by uh
passionate re-affirmations of
commitments to Republican values of
equality and solidarity and the disorder
that you described again is extremely
limited it is of course regrettable but
it does not Mark the general atmosphere
or tone of life or Society our politics
in Ireland on the contrary Ireland is
stable and peaceful and optimistic and
forward-looking and you cite those
limited incidents and of course they
catch the headlines because they're
dramatic and and they should not happen
I mean let me just say that absolutely
but they are marked by the fact that
this is a very very limited phenomenon
Now in Ireland and that's the real
measure of what has been so
painstakingly and successfully built now
over a quarter of a century by all of us
working in Partnership let me take you
back to where we started Mary Lou
McDonald then I must let you go I know
we were talking about
um Biden and his involvement or
otherwise in Northern Ireland politics
and the reason I was asking you because
uh former British Prime Minister Tony
Blair he's warned that American
influence on Northern Ireland politics
has to be used with care and sensitivity
well I I think Karen's sensitivity is is
necessary uh all round isn't it because
we're we're dealing with um a situation
where we we have a disputed border still
on our Island there are those of us that
wish for Irish reunification we will
work day in Daily democratically and
peacefully for that and there are others
who wish to see the maintenance of the
union and it's a very very live debate
and it needs to be a respectful debate
so I absolutely agree with Tony Blair
that that the care and caution and above
all else respect has to be at the core
of our dealings and I have to say that I
have seen nothing and would anticipate
nothing less than a very very respectful
but also a very energetic very positive
presentation from the United States uh
president the home after all of what we
call a can-do attitude and I for one
welcome that that level of momentum at
this point in time to our process and I
hope it gets a good and fair and a
respectful hearing and I hope that we
see the dup rise to the occasion respond
to the moment and above all else respond
to the Democratic wishes of the people
expressed almost a year ago and that we
got Michelle O'Neill in as the first
Minister for all and we get government
going and let's let's get the work done
let's start serving the people fully
okay great to see you busy day thank you
thanks so much okay thank you chatting
to Peter West mccot earlier the former
UK ambassador to the U.S he was working
in the Embassy in Washington when the
Clinton Administration granted Jerry
Adams a Visa he told me how the UK
reacted
that was the time Robin Reddick was the
Ambassador Jonathan Powell Tony Blairs
chief of staff for shortly afterwards uh
and I were all in the embassy at the
time and we were not impressed at the
way in which the advice of the British
government a close Ally not to give
visas to Jerry Adams mud McGuinness uh
was it ignored by the White House we
thought that it was premature before the
business of of using violence in pursuit
of political objectives uh had been set
to one side by uh so uh it was a moment
of some difficulty I think it was almost
five days that John Major didn't take a
phone call from President Clinton to
discuss this afterwards but I think and
I've written this afterwards I think
that with hindsight partly because we
were so enraged by that it turned out to
be a risk for peace that was worth
taking and it bound the uh it bound the
leadership of shinophen and to some
extent the IRA into a peace process from
which there was no Escape unless they
were going to burn their Bridges with
the the Clinton White House and they
really didn't want to do that so it was
one of those moments when although we
didn't like it I I would say with
hindsight that it was a helpful
intervention by the US government